let's go to our next caller from the 202
area code 202 this is this could be
right in the heart of the American
capital of Washington DC caller from -
OH - who's this where you're calling
from hey David it's a pleasure to be on
with you that's actually hilarious that
you say that because I'm the exact
opposite of the last caller I'm actually
the - OH - number I come from DC but I'm
actually a local call it I'm calling
some awesome Massachusetts right now
really close to you guys well yeah my
question is uh basically I need help
reconciling two positions you always
hear about America's foreign policy and
our role in the world there's the whole
chomskyan view how we've been such a
terrible influence to so many different
places clearly undeniable South America
Middle East
Vietnam places like that we've had a you
know terrible impact made some terrible
calculations you know some not just out
of malevolence somewhere you know
probably good decisions that turned out
terribly either way then there's the
other view that we have been sort of a
benevolent giant since 1945 and you know
there's obviously a lot to hold down up
as well there was relatively peaceful
you know are our friends really
generally loved US and Europe and you
know in Japan or South Korea so I need
help reconciling these views the way I
try to reconcile and I want you to know
I want you to reply tell me you think
this kind of makes sense that as far as
our foreign policy legacy since 1945
it's been pretty good in the first world
countries and pretty abysmal in the
third world countries it's always a
little bit simplistic but you generally
agree with that I think that there are
probably counter examples but it's it's
an interesting way way to sort of think
about it I mean the the reconciling of
the views can happen pretty simply which
is that just because we have the means
and arguably sometimes the intentions of
being a positive influence around the
world doesn't mean that we always make
the right call and it doesn't mean that
even when we make the right call in
principle that it actually ends up
working out the right way so a lot of it
has to do with so there's a couple
different ways that we would evaluate
whether a foreign intervention or
involvement made
cents right sometimes we think about it
from like the humanitarian cause which
is were we ostensibly like on the right
side or fighting for the value that made
sense that's number one number two
becomes more utilitarian which is did
the did what we lost the the losses
justify the potential gains that there
were and or the actual gains that we
achieved and then there's what you
talked about in terms of alliances right
which is how are the alliances and sort
of the geopolitical implications of what
we did around the world how did that
work out but we can step back from that
a little bit and there's people who take
much more absolutist views on this who
say I am isolationist unless it doesn't
matter what the humanitarian situation
is it doesn't matter who else is at risk
if the United States is not directly at
risk and that could be like a foreign
military base in another country you
could define that however you want we do
not get involved because we are simply
not the world police officer that would
that would be like one view another view
would be if we have the means anytime
there is suffering that we could
conceivably alleviate it is our duty and
responsibility to get involved the
problem is that a lot of the
interventions aren't on that spectrum it
would be lovely to think that
everything's on that spectrum and it's
about where we draw the line there are
interventions that are done to try to
secure resources right oil being a
popular one and that's sort of on a
different scale altogether and we kind
of need a different barometer altogether
if that makes sense mm-hmm yeah and then
there's obviously the problem where we
have such a you know a bad reputation in
so many parts of the world so even if we
do have a sort of benevolent reason to
go and do this new venture I mean
everyone will obviously expect the worst
in certain parts of the world even in
the cases where they are wrong what you
know obviously works against us and
those times where we do have benevolent
intention hey um what's going on in
Austin these days is it getting crazy or
is it gentrifying uh there's definitely
the Jets are flying I mean you know it's
you know the smell is definitely the
same the smell hasn't gentrified that
has remained constant and
to imagine the stench will ever go away
but in general you know it's still all
the great music the great food and the
terrible smell you still got all that
whole thanks also doing well it's
holding up very good college
neighborhood at Boston Berry College
neighborhood for sure for sure I love
Alston myself alright thanks very much
for the call appreciate it always good
to hear from people in the area that's
always great stuff